hello folks and welcome back to the show
on this episode we're pitting a guy who
talks like a child against the guy who
talks out of his butt hey I can do both
those things but I'm not a comedy mega
superstar like mr. Adam Sandler or dr.
Jim Carrey Jim's not an actual doctor
but he plays one in the new Sonic the
Hedgehog movie call me when we get an
echo the dolphin trilogy ha ha this is a
matchup of two guys we love even if we
don't love all the movies they make they
are homerun hitters and they've been
responsible for some of the biggest
comedies and the hardiest guffaws of all
time oh and they're not bad on the
dramatic side of the ball as well
they've got it all but only one will
take the top prize here's how we figure
it out
round 1 box office round 2 tomato meter
round 3 awards and then we'll do a
wild-card round to settle the score when
rendering my decision I promise to be a
fair and impartial judge why because I
can't lie the pen is blue and we're off
to a hot start no yelling on the bus you
want a piece of meat you want to play
rough
daddy can play rough not one box on
silly and goofy though they may be Adam
Sandler and Jim Carrey are phenomenal at
making movies that make boatloads of
cash can't make the scene if you don't
have the green they first gained
critical acclaim and our hearts on
television and then would enter the
box-office stratosphere for Sailor it
was the steady climb in dollars earned
from early cult favorites like Billy
Madison and happy gilmore to monster
smashes like the waterboy and Big Daddy
all told his flicks have grossed 3.7
billion dollars domestically and six
point four billion dollars across the
globe making for an impressive 190
million dollar average for his 34 movies
Jim Carrey had a slightly different
trajectory and that he rocketed to
comedy movie superstardom in one year
1994 the same year that featured a
baseball strike and boys to men
promising to make love to us like we
want them to also could be considered
the single best year any actor has ever
had Jim had Ace Ventura pet
in February the mask in July and dumb
and Dumberer that December that's a
career for most people but Kerry was
just getting started
he's gone on to make 31 films that have
gross that combined 4.1 billion dollars
domestically and seven point four
billion dollars internationally for a
very impressive average of two hundred
and thirty nine million dollars per
flick for both fellows those averages
only look more glossy when you consider
the fact that they had box office duds
like that's my boy underrated in my
opinion and the number 23 no one saw it
and let's keep it that way this category
sounds like an easy win for Jim Carrey
but hang on Adam Sandler has been
focused on streaming movies the last few
years after signing a blockbuster deal
with Netflix according to them films
like murder-mystery have accrued
astronomical amounts of views boom we
don't have specific numbers for you
because apparently Netflix is data rep
is dr. claw not to be confused with
what's yourself it's Nicole Oh Adam
Sandler streaming dominance and the fact
that he continued to make hit movies
well into the arts
whereas carries box-office clout dipped
considerably after the new millennium is
enough to give Adam the win in round one
well-done canteen boy
[Music]
now to today to me as I so eloquently
stated in round one Jim Carrey's movie
career took off like a comet in 1994 but
today one could argue he's almost as
well known for what a great dramatic
actor he is it's the more serious movies
that rank higher on the tomato meter
Jim's best film according to that is The
Truman Show 94% to be fair his worst
film on the tomato meter is also a
serious role as dark crimes is currently
stinky at 0%
but overall carries average is a
respectable 51% to Sandler's rotten 37%
so you hear my opening salvo and you say
how can anyone compete well exit light
and enter sandman' he can go dramatic -
and it's his role in the mire with
stories that have given him his best
tomato meter score at 93% Adam also has
a seer percent on the resume that being
the ridiculous six I'll tell you what's
ridiculous that we're not talking about
these fellas with their comedies that
rank on the tomato meter sailors highest
funny flicks are the wedding singer at
68% and happy gilmore at 61% the price
is wrong [ __ ] justice for Big Daddy
where's that 40 percent come on the only
good news is it I am sure it will be
immortalized in rotten movies we love
available now let's take a look no okay
but that does have Billy Madison Ace
Ventura and the Cable Guy in it Rotten
movies we love now available at Walden
books in the mall no way
Carrie dominates Sandler in the
critically acclaimed comedy game his
highest rated yuk fests are liar liar at
81% the mask at 78% and Dumb and Dumber
at 67% which begs the question you want
to hear the most annoying sound in the
world I'm kidding I wouldn't do that to
y'all let's hold our collective
where was that anyway let's hold our
collective noses and go back to the
rotten side of the tomato meter at its
lowest depth is where Adam Saylor
unfortunately dominates if you combine
these two superstars is ten worst films
than the tomato meter Sandler has eight
of them including Jack and Jill at 3%
who gave Jack and Jill a fresh review
certainly not George C Scott the talking
bottom line is that Jim Carrey and Adam
Sandler have plenty of fresh movies but
they also made us laugh so hard in their
guilty pleasure films in this round I'm
giving Jim Carrey the win he's on the
board and we're all tied up at one oh I
know it sounds quelle ridiculous be a
deciding factor in a contest between Jim
Kerr and Adam Sandler but if the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
won't recognize these talented titans of
titillation I have no choice but to take
matters into my own hands maybe stick to
Sciences Academy because you're way off
on the motion picture arts part I don't
think I fully understand how that phrase
work both fellows have been robbed by
the Oscars in my overconfident opinion
Carrie could have easily won for a man
on the moon or eternal sunshine of the
spot was mine and Sandler was great in
uncut gems but Oscar ain't the only
prize you can win if you were good in a
talking picture the Golden Globes are
another prestigious night of drinking
and memes and they have recognized the
greatness of Jim Carrey before he was
first nominated for best comedic
performance for the mask anyone twice
for the Truman Show and man on the moon
all told the Pet Detective has gathered
95 total nominations and 47 wins so
there's no way Adam Saylor can't compete
with that that isn't him mr. Frodo don't
get short with me
he's got more yep happy has a hundred
and thirteen nominations and 61 wins
although to be fair none of those came
from major award shows
but for uncut gems he did win Best Actor
for the AARP movies for grown-ups award
so that's what's in those letters that
AARP keeps sending me I'm three
nine guys you don't come up yet what's
wrong with you how long have you been in
show business Sandman is also on a
Razzie three times can you guess the
movies I'll give you a second Jack and
Jill duh that's my boy easy and Big
Daddy it's a great movie what are you I
need a therapist
Oh buddy I'm sorry oh man I hope to keep
hearing the names Carrie and Sandler in
award seasons future however for this
round it's Jim Carrey that has been
winning and getting snubbed for longer
so he gets the win which I'm sure is
just as good as actually winning an
Oscar I mean give these guys an Academy
Award if for no other reason
you know the speech is gonna be
hysterical most brain we've been talking
a lot about how funny these guys are
while also gushing about their ability
to go dramatic when necessary but whom
has the most range and before we even
take a look at serious roles let's
investigate range inside the world of
comedy Jim Carrey obviously has a
penchant for over the top physical
hilarity as evidenced by everything from
the ace Ventura's to the mask to me
myself and I read but he also showed a
subdued ability to be funny and touching
in flicks like The Truman Show and I
love you Philip Morris even when he is
really funny he can also be a more
grounded everyman in movies such as
Bruce Almighty and liar liar
meanwhile I could try to describe the
different levels of Adam Sandler
but our expert researcher Mark Hoffmeyer
they clap for him more than they clap
for me categorize Sandler into subtler
subgenres of his comedic persona there
is normal Sandler 50 first dates the
wedding singer and my personal favorite
et Cie Oh ads that's just etc he's got a
lot of movie roles like that that one
setting and wanting to choke on your
spam and then there's athletes Ambler
happy gilmore The Longest Yard weird
voice Sandler Little Nicky you don't
mess with the Zohan and manchild Sandler
Big Daddy and as a nice transition into
dramatic range there's Adam Sandler with
a great director as evidence in roles
like Punch Drunk Love and uncut gems
meanwhile Jim Carrey went full serious
and Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind and went full method is Andy
Kaufman and man on the moon both get
major kudos for having an extensive
range but Jim Carrey gets - not for me
just look at what he did in his magic
year of 1994 and then a year and a half
later he totally subverted audience
expectations with the decidedly darker
the Cable Guy chip juice this up and Jim
goes up three two one and the winner is
let me just quickly thank both these
gentlemen for all the incredible moments
of pure hilarity that they provided one
thinks of Jim Carrey beating himself up
in the bathroom and Liar Liar or of Adam
Sandler battling Bob Barker in the
middle of a golf tournament now you've
had enough [ __ ] all-time great laughs
from two legends of the game in the end
I would give Jim Carrey the not because
of his funniest movies he's the main
reason why were laughing so hard there
is an asterisk next to that statement
for Dumb and Dumber to Jeff Daniels he's
arguably as funny as Jim in that movie
and what an achievement that is and then
there's Adam Sandler who to his credit
is more than happy to share the wealth
of laughs with his good buddy some of
the best moments from Sandler's best
comedies are from Carl Weathers Kathy
Bates and of course the legendary Chris
Farley
so for being funny talented and able to
put an entire movie on his back the win
goes to Jim Carrey from one former
comedy store door guy to another but I'm
just a dude you're the viewer who has
opinions that really count vote right
now in the comment section type your
winner and feel free to give us as much
or as little
texts as you like and if you want to say
something nice about the host alrighty
then I'm Mark Ellis and until next time
bye pretty good after man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]